>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Thea Austen: Good evening.
Hi, everybody.
Hi. Thank you for coming.
Thank you so much.
I'm Thea Austen.
I'm the public events
coordinator
for the American
Folk Life Center.
And on behalf of all of
our staff, we really want
to thank you for coming tonight
for a very special evening.
This is part of the Homegrown
series which was created
to showcase the best
of traditional music,
dance and narrative arts
from around the country,
and sometimes from
beyond the country.
We usually work with state
folklorists and with partners
like the Millennium Stage at the
Kennedy Center and hold these
in college auditoriums.
But this time we're changing up.
We came into a more
intimate space
for a very special performance.
You can find more information
about the Folk Life Center
outside on the tables
where you'll also see DVDs
and CDs and things like that
by our two performers.
So I want to make
sure you take a look
at that later after the show.
Just a little bit of
housekeeping in that we have
to make sure that everybody's
out of the building by 9:30
because the magical electric
magnetic door locks spring
into action and the cops don't
even have control of them.
So we need to make sure
everybody gets out by then.
Also we love mobile phones.
We really do.
The Veterans History
Project which is part
of the Folk Life
Center even has an app
to help you do oral
histories with your family
and then submit them
for our collections.
But we don't want your
phones ringing right now.
So if you haven't
turned them off,
please turn off your phones.
So why are you all here?
Well, in the 1970s,
cousins Connie Regan Blake
and Barbara Freeman
were both working
at the Chattanooga
Public Library,
Barbara as a children's
librarian and Connie
as a full-time storyteller
for a special outreach
program called More.
And I think she was called
Miss Daisy and had a blue dress
with daisies all over it.
In 1973, they attended the first
National Storytelling Festival
in Jonesborough, Tennessee.
That's where they met Ray and
Rosa Hicks of Beach Mountain,
North Carolina who became
lasting friends and mentors.
They realized they had a
special gift for telling stories
and they left their jobs, left
their careers at the library
to perform nationally and
internationally as folk tellers.
Connie and Barbara pioneered
tandem telling which is a type
of duet storytelling
performance.
And they were on the founding
board of directors for NAPPS,
the National Association for the
Preservation and Perpetuation
of Storytelling which is
now called the National
Storytelling Network.
In 1985, the folk tellers moved
to Asheville, North Carolina
and began working on a play
entitled Mountain Sweet Talk.
This two-act, fully staged play
starred Connie and Barbara,
incorporating original
materials and stories
from the folk tellers.
The show ran for seven seasons,
1986-1992 with over
300 performances.
And I think it's the
longest-running play,
right, in Asheville.
The folk tellers also
toured across the country,
performing at folk festivals
including the Smithsonian
Festival here in Washington.
Connie and Barbara eventually
moved on to solo careers
and both are
internationally-recognized
storytellers.
Connie Regen-Blake's collection
of recordings, photographs,
correspondence and memorabilia
with documents both
her storytelling career
and the larger storytelling
scene from the 1970's
to the present day is
part of the archive
of the American Folk
Life Center.
So in this special evening
program, the two cousins
and performing partners
step back in time
to perform together once again.
Please welcome Connie
Regen-Blake and Barbara Freeman.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
For an encore we will --
>> We are very excited to be
here and doing this and we're
so glad each one of
you all came tonight.
It would be a very different
experience if you had not.
We still would have been
telling, but we're glad
to have you here,
delighted for it.
And we're going to start
with one of our favorites,
and it's called No News
or What Killed the Dog.
On Edison Records --
>> It was gifted to
us by Marshall Dodge.
>> A certain southern
lady was returning home
after recuperating in the
mountains for three months.
My friend --
>> Georgianna.
>> Met me at the
railroad station platform.
Georgianna, has there been
any news while I've been away?
>> No. No news.
>> No news?
Surely something must have
happened in my absence.
I've been gone for most nearly
three months and I am anxious
for any little bit
of news you may have.
>> Well, since you mentioned
it, of course it don't amount
to much, but since you've
been away, your dog died.
>> My dog died?
>> Yeah, he went over and ate
some of the burnt horse flesh
and that's what killed the dog.
>> Burnt horse flesh?
>> See, after the fire
cooled off, the dog went over
and ate some of the
burnt horse flesh
and that's what killed the dog.
>> After the fire cooled off?
>> See, the barn burned down,
burned up all the
cows and horses.
The fire cooled off, the
dog went over and ate some
of the burnt horse flesh and
that's what killed your dog.
>> My barn burned down?
How did my barn burn down?
>> Oh, it was a spark
from the house.
See, it flew over, landed
on the roof of the barn,
burned down the barn, burned
up all the cows and horses.
The fire cooled off, the
dog went over and ate some
of the burnt horse flesh.
That's what killed the dog.
>> A spark from the house?
>> Oh yes, now that's
completely burned down.
>> Well how did my
house burn down?
>> It was those candles.
They just kind of caught on
the curtains, shot up the side
of the wall, burned
down the house.
A spark fell on the
roof of the barn --
>> Candles?
Georgianna, I don't have
any candles in the house.
I don't even allow
candles in the house.
How did candles get
in the house?
>> Oh, they was around
the coffin.
[ Laughter ]
>> The coffin?
Who died?
>> Oh, now, you needn't
worry about that.
Since you've been away,
your mother-in-law died.
>> Oh. My mother-in-law,
what a pity.
[ Laughter ]
How did she die?
>> Well some folks say it
was from the shock of hearing
that your husband ran off
with the choir leader.
[ Laughter ]
But other than that,
there ain't been no news.
>> May all your news
be good news.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This thing is
starting up my nose.
Should I pull it back down?
>> I think so, or get
Everett if we need to.
>> That's good.
>> Is that okay?
>> Let me try here.
>> Is it hiding my dimple?
It's the only good
feature I have.
>> Okay, are we still
okay on sound, everybody?
Still good.
And I know some of you folks
in here go back a long way
with the folk tellers, right
back to the very beginnings
of the folk tellers in 1975.
So it's really fun
to be breathing this
air into these stories.
And this next one is
a traditional story.
We always loved to think about
Ray Hicks, his wife Rosa,
bring them on stage with us.
And kind of in that
way they influenced
so much of what we do.
And we have such
gratitude to them.
But this is one of the
grandfather tales that we took
and made a little folk
tellerese within it.
And it is like this.
>> Once upon a time --
>> Back when turkeys
chewed tobacco --
>> And clog dancers
had wooden feet --
>> There were two women.
>> Regina May.
>> And Willa Mena.
>> Now these two women
were the best of friends.
>> But they lived in a community
where folks were
always at one another.
>> Whenever anyone got together,
they'd start into arguing back
and forth and back and forth.
Arguing about who could
stitch the prettiest quilt.
>> Or who could spit the
furthest or who could check
out the most library
books in an hour.
>> You know, that sort of thing.
>> Well, one day
the two women got
to talking about their husbands.
>> And how foolish
they could act.
>> And they got to talking
about what was the craziest,
most foolish thing
they'd ever done.
Now they were both experts
on this particular subject.
They had plenty to draw upon.
And they started
making out a list.
comparing notes.
Then their tempers
started to flare.
>> Their voices got
louder and louder
and they got into an argument.
>> And they commenced to stare
one another down and going back
and forth and forth and back.
>> And forth and back.
>> Until finally it came
about that the only
way to settle this --
>> Was to make a bet.
>> A bet as to which one's
husband would prove himself
to be the biggest fool.
And they gave each other
a week to do it in.
>> Now Willa Mena knew she
would have no trouble with a bet
like that because
she was married
to the world's very
best hypochondriac.
He was always sick,
getting sicker.
If somebody came in and
said they had a headache,
within a few seconds you would
hear Willa Mena's husband say,
"I think I've got a headache,
and a [coughing] cold too."
So out of sheer love for him,
whenever Willa Mena had any
free time at all, she would go
and pull books off their shelf
and she would flip through them
to see if any book bothered to
mention a disease or a symptom.
And if she found
something in print,
I'm sorry to say she's just rip
out the page, because she knew
if her old man got ahold
of a book that talked
about a disease, he
would come down with it.
And she would have
to deal with it.
So she thought she
would just use
that little tidbit for the bet.
So when he came walking
through the front door,
Willa Mena started
in with a question.
"Honey, do you feel all right?"
He said he thought he felt fine,
but he was open for suggestions.
[ Laughter ]
She said, "Just come
over here, honey.
Slowly, slowly, slowly,
sit yourself down.
You're looking like puny.
I'm going to fix you
up as best I can."
She ran out to her little herb
garden and she ripped herself
up some angelica and
some spignent to thicken
and thin his blood
in due course.
And then she threw
in some ginseng just
to confuse the other two.
She kind of force-fed
him throughout the day
and he had a big old
smile all over his face
because he was feeling
pretty good,
getting all that
attention from Willa Mena.
Well, the next morning, bright
and early, before he was awake,
she took him by the
shoulders and she shook him.
"Honey Bunch, stick
out your tongue.
I hope you're not going to put
that tongue back
into your mouth.
From the looks of it, you've
done come down with something.
But I'm going to keep you
alive the best I can."
And by that evening, that
smile had flattened out
and turned completely upside
down into one serious frown.
>> Meanwhile, back
at Regina May's,
she had a different tactic
for winning that bet.
When her husband come walking
through the cabin door,
she's sitting behind her loom,
throwing that shuttle back
and forth, clicking and clacking
and clicking and clacking.
And it without a single
piece of threat on it.
Her husband, he came over and
he looked and watched and looked
and finally he said,
"Regina May,
what is it that you're doing?"
She said, "Why, I'm weaving."
And before he could say another
word or ask another question,
she came back with
an, "Oh, this is some
of the finest thread I
have ever worked with.
Folks told me it comes
from virgin sheep.
And any husband lying to his
wife can't even see it at all."
[ Laughter ]
He peered down just a little bit
closer, took off his spectacles,
cleaned them and said, "You
know, I believe that may be some
of the finest thread
I've ever laid eyes on."
And she just smiled real big and
for the next two or three days,
whenever her husband come
walking through the cabin door,
there she sat, behind that loom,
throwing that empty shuttle
back and forth in midair.
>> Meanwhile, back
at Willa Mena's,
she had done a wonderful job
of convincing her old man
that he was a near goner.
She scooted up a little chair
alongside of his bed and looked
at him real pitiful-like and
she said, "Honey, I'm sure going
to miss you when you're gone."
[Sobbing] She cried on.
"And I just hate to tell
you this, but I've done gone
and had your coffin made.
And while you've got just
enough strength left in you,
you sure could help
me out a powerful lot
if you would just help
me get you on into it."
[ Laughter ]
She drug that coffin box
over near the bed,
parallel to the bed.
And she said, "It just pains
me to ask you to move yourself
from your snug little deathbed
over into your coffin."
"Yeah, Willa Mena,
that's plumb awful.
But I'm thinking there's
something worse than that.
When a friend dies, you lose
a friend, but when you die,
I think you lose
all your friends."
[Sobbing] And she used that
opportunity to get him on a roll
and she got him right
down into that coffin box.
She thought it was a good sign
too, because he landed face-up.
She reached over and
petted him on the forehead
and by the time he closed those
beady little hypochondriac eyes,
I'll be if he didn't
look downright grave.
>> Meanwhile, back
at Regina May's,
she figured she'd spent
enough time behind that loom.
So the next time her
husband came walking
through the cabin
door, she said, "Honey,
would you help me
move this here bolt
of cloth over to that table."
She said, "Watch out, don't
let it drag the floor."
And he just raised
his arms up higher.
She got over the table and was
acting like she was spreading
out a piece of material,
got her a pair of scissors
and she went to cutting.
Now he watched and looked and
watched and finally he said,
"Regina May, what is
it that you're making?"
She said, "Well, I'm
making you the finest suit
of clothes you'll ever put on."
And she kept cutting.
Then she got her a needle and
some of that special thread
and she went over and sat down
and went to stitching, sewing in
and out, in and out, stitching
up nothing but thin air.
Her husband watched for a
little while and then he went
on to bed, and she
sat up half the night.
Next morning, first
thing she said, "Honey,
it's ready for you to try on."
He came into the parlor
and she held up like this
and he figured, "That
must be the pants."
He took one leg and
then the other.
She said, "Raise your arms up."
And he just knew
that was the shirt.
She went right over the top.
She help up one more
time and he thought,
"That must be the jacket."
So he kind of backed right
into it and she said,
"Now would you look at that?
Turn around there."
He turned around twice and
she said, "Now, you know,
I think it's a perfect fit."
And he was standing there in
nothing but a pair of boots.
[ Laughter ]
>> That same crystal clear
morning, Willa Mena leaned
over the coffin box
and said, "Oh, me.
He's done died during
the night."
And her old man figured
she must be right.
[ Laughter ]
So Willa Mena got real busy
and she spread word
throughout the entire community.
She wanted everybody to
gather down at the cemetery
for what could turn out to be
a pretty good revival of sorts.
And she got a neighbor
friends to help her load
up that old heavy
wooden coffin box full
of her husband onto the wagon.
And she hitched up
the team of horses
and she started on
off down the road.
And she got to the burying
grounds and folks were clustered
and gathered all about.
And who should be coming down
the sawmill road but Regina May
and her old man, and him
in his new suit of clothes.
He's walking along telling
folks howdy, shaking hands
with every other
one, telling them all
about this fine new suit of
clothes his wife made him
and all about that special
quality of those virgin sheep.
Folks didn't quite
know what to do.
I mean, this was their neighbor.
They'd known him all his life,
but they'd honestly never
seen him in this light before.
[ Laughter ]
Mostly they were just staring.
Then a few of the children
started giggling just a
little bit.
>> And then old Preacher
Dry Fry just started howling
and laughing and slapping his
legs and made so much noise
and so much ruckus that
the dead man got curious.
He sat up in his coffin to
see what was going on and all.
>> And when he did that,
folks just took off
running in all directions.
>> And then the corpse must have
got a glimpse of his neighbor,
and maybe some of
what was happening.
Because he started laughing
and rocking that coffin box,
almost fell out of it.
>> Then it dawned on folks,
there was some foolishness
going on.
>> So they all came back to
find out what all had happened.
And they all discovered
that Regina May
and Willa Mena had done
gone and made a bet as to
which one was married
to the biggest fool.
>> Both of which were
now currently on display.
[ Laughter ]
>> Now you may have
made up in your mind,
decided which one won the bet.
But we need to tell
you that Regina May
and Willa Mena never settled it.
>> Why you can come into
the community day or night.
You will still hear
Regina May and Willa Mena
and their husbands and all
the folks are still betting
about it.
>> They're arguing
about it, going back
and forth and forth and back.
>> Why they sound
downright foolish.
>> You bet.
[ Applause ]
>> I want you to know this
is only like the second time
in a long time that we
have had this opportunity
and taken the opportunity
to tell together.
So it makes it extra
special for tonight.
We're going to end this
little tandem part --
each of us are going to go
and we'll be each
doing a short solo set.
And then I think a few Q and A's
if you all have any
questions or interview.
And then we're going to end on a
tandem as well at the very end.
But to end this set, we're going
to do another favorite, right?
>> Are we going to do Jazzy?
>> Yes.
>> Let's do it.
>> And this is one we learned
from Shoshana Coriscov.
She was five years old
when she taught it to us.
We spiffed it up a
little bit here and there,
filled in a few blanks
and it goes like this.
>> Fulfilleries I
think we call it.
>> I think that's it.
And it goes like this.
>> Once upon a time in a nursery
rhyme, there were three bears.
I said three bears.
They all went a-walking through
the green woods a-talking.
Along come a little girl
with long shiny golden hair.
Her name was --
>> Goldilocks.
>> Her name was --
>> Upon the door she knocked.
Baboom, baboom, baboom,
boom, boom.
>> But no one was there.
>> No.
>> No one was there.
She walked right in, had herself
a ball, a-eating and a-rocking
and a-sleeping and all.
>> She didn't care
no one was there.
>> She didn't care.
>> Wa-wa-wa-wa-wa home
came the three bears,
tired from the woods.
Ready to sit down to some
homecooked goods, yeah.
>> "Someone's been
eating my porridge,"
said the Papa bear,
said the Mama bear.
>> "Hey Mama, she-bear,"
said that little wee bear.
"Someone has broken my chair."
>> Well they went upstairs
to see what they could find,
saw Goldilocks in bed
asleep all the time.
She woke up, broke up the party
and boogied on out of there.
>> "Ba-doom bye,"
said the Papa bear.
"Ba-doom bye," said
the Mama bear.
>> "Hey Mama, she-bear,"
said that little wee bear.
"What kind of bear
was that there, huh?"
>> And that is the story
of the three bears,
I said the three bears.
>> I said the three.
>> I said the three bears.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> I'm going off to play.
>> Yep.
>> Oh, thank you so much.
And I didn't actually tell
my video person I was going
to be walking over here.
But I'm going to very quickly
-- the way I work on stories is
to record them, so I'm going
to record this little set here.
And so you know,
I get my stories
from lots of different places.
And sometimes from
the newspaper.
This one is a Family Circus
cartoon, just a little bit
that I would like
to share with you.
It's one of my favorites.
The Mama was sitting
and reading a folk tale,
fairy tale, to her little boy.
He was sitting right on her
lap, and they got to the ending
and the Mama said, "And they
lived happily ever after."
And that little boy said, "Boy,
I did not see that coming."
[ Laughter ]
And I have to say, with
this life unfolding
of doing storytelling, I
did not see this coming.
But I am so grateful that
everything that happened,
that Barbara introduced
me to storytelling.
She was the first one to
open that door and say,
I think you can do this.
And then our wonderful career
together and now with both
of us doing solo work, it
has been quite a journey.
And in these years, storytelling
has taken me to all 50 states,
34 countries and six
continents so far.
And I think it works out well
that I happen to love to travel.
And I also am fascinated
by maps.
I always have been.
You know, this idea
of holding something.
Now some of you here maybe
have never held a paper map.
But it used to be that you would
fold out or have small ones
and I still like to
do that sometimes.
Because those maps, they really
represent sometimes hundreds
or thousands of miles,
different terrain, you know,
landscapes, lakes and mountains.
A dot can represent a
city of 20 million people.
Vast oceans.
There's this magic that
comes with these maps.
And I happen, whenever
I'm traveling
out of the United States,
I always travel with
a laminated map.
I actually brought
it with me tonight.
And once, a few years
back, I was in kind
of an isolated place in China.
I was at the Wei Chin
temple in the gardens.
And that's right at
the base of Mt. Washan.
And I was going to be
climbing up that mountain.
I was kind of gathering myself.
I'd been practicing on our
steep driveway for months.
And I was very excited about it.
But I was walking
through the gardens
and no other westerners around.
And I smiled at one
of the villagers
and right away they came up to
me and indicated they wanted
to have someone take their
picture of themselves and me.
They wanted a picture with me.
And I was a little bit
flattered, but it was only later
that I found out there are
not many gray-haired people
in China.
[ Laughter ]
And so it was a little of that,
there was a little
ulterior motive
that they were wanting
this picture with me.
But I don't speak any Mandarin.
I don't speak any
of the dialects.
But I did what I always
do when I'm traveling.
I pulled out this laminated map.
It's a small one,
folds in threes.
And on one side is the world.
So I turned it to the
world side and pointed
to where we were
in eastern China.
And then I pointed to the
United states, you know, for me.
And then I turned
that map over --
and almost everyone
everywhere I've traveled,
no matter how remote
the place might be,
people seem to know
the English words
"New York and San Francisco."
And so I pointed those
out on this larger map
of the United States.
And then I pointed
to North Carolina,
Asheville where I was living.
Back to me.
And like that, we were talking.
We were having this conversation
without knowing each
other's languages.
I also travel with photographs.
And I had some pictures
of my husband Phil
and of the Appalachian
mountains where we live,
a picture of my cat Alaska.
And by this time, a few more
people had joined our circle
and it was getting kind
of bigger and bigger.
And people took the
photos and they started,
and then someone else walked
up and someone was showing
that person her husband,
and this is her cat.
And showing I was able to
hear some of those words
with a mandarin accent.
And it was really quite
magical and extraordinary to me,
to know that this map is this
gateway to communicating.
This way of without
knowing other languages,
it really opens the
door to that.
So I have always had this
fascination with maps.
So as you might imagine, for a
map geek, I was quite delighted
when Google Maps came along.
And I used it quite
a bit, and a number
of years ago I was invited
to come down to Australia
to do some storytelling
in a workshop.
And the people that had hired
me had sent me the address
of the workshop.
And I had a friend who was
living right outside --
the workshop was
going to be in Sydney.
And I had a friend
who was living outside
of Sydney at the time.
And I thought, "Oh,
I wonder where she is
in relationship to
this workshop.
Maybe she could attend
or something."
And so I went straight
to Google and I typed
in 1154 New Trion Road, South
Wales, Sydney, Australia.
And you know, Google
located that.
And the next thing, if you use
Google, the next thing that pops
up is your home address.
And I thought, "Huh, I wonder
how Google would take me
from Asheville to Australia."
So I pressed Get Directions.
And without thinking,
I pressed print.
[ Laughter ]
17 pages later, I had
intricate directions for my home
on Vance Gap to New Trion Road.
So Google suggested, as I
was imagining my way west,
Google suggested 40 and
then heading up to Chicago;
from Chicago over to Nebraska,
and then taking I-84
into Boise, Idaho.
I thought that was an
interesting choice.
[ Laughter ]
Then I was to continue west.
And when I got to
the Oregon coast,
Google said, get in your kayak.
[ Laughter ]
2,786 miles later, which took
14 days and 5 hours according
to Google, I came to
the shore of Hawaii.
Now Google already knew that
there was a road closure
and so I was going to
have to take a detour.
But I made my way.
I was starting across.
You know, and I saw
signs for Honolulu,
and I must admit I was
tempted to make a side trip.
But I thought, "No, I have
got to keep my focus."
Plus I was lugging that kayak.
So I got all the way to
the other end of Hawaii
and Google distinctly said for
me to get back in that kayak,
and I was to go 3,879
miles to Japan.
Now it was on this
part of the trip
that I passed the
international date line.
Not only the time changes,
but the date changes.
It was the first time in my life
that I had a geographical reason
to be a day behind myself.
I landed in Japan and I
was to go just a half-mile
and pick -- oh my goodness.
Oh, all of a sudden the
directions where in Kanji.
All of the signs were
in the Japanese language
with characters.
But somehow I made
my way down Japan,
the whole country,
paying a few tolls.
I had to take a ferry.
But then Google insisted
I get back in the kayak
and 17 days later, I hit
landfall at Australia.
And it was a relatively
easy trip down to Sydney.
[ Laughter ]
Now at that point, I had
been working out a lot.
And I do a modified Crossfit
and I was deadlifting.
At the time I was
deadlifting 82 pounds
and I was doing dead
arm hangs and squats.
But I must admit, Google
had a better opinion
of my physical capabilities than
I did, thinking that I could be
in open waters in the
Pacific 11,233 miles.
But I'll tell you, I have
continued working out.
Let me get something
here and I'll show you.
And I continued working out
and I am actually now
deadlifting double what I was
deadlifting then.
I'm the strongest I've
ever been in my life.
So who knows?
Maybe I will give it a try, and
if I do, I have the directions.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Oh my. This happened a few
years ago, and I went back --
you know, I was in my office
late that night and I got
so tickled, I almost
lost my breath when all
of this started printing out.
And I went back about two
or three months after that
and I thought, "You
know, I'm just going
to print out another copy."
By then they were already
saying, "Cannot calculate."
So this might -- Library of
Congress is getting this copy
and this might be one of the
only copies of directions
from 51 Vance Gap, Asheville
to New South Wales, Sydney.
So I'm going to -- let me
just check my time here.
Yeah, good.
So I'd like to tell you, take
you back on that journey,
change the mood with
this next story
and tell you another favorite.
Especially from the early days.
It's one that really
became my signature story.
And I feel it's one that
helped take Barbara and I
onto main stages of
folk music festivals all
over the United States.
Because I think for a lot of
people it was like, "Oh yes,
storytelling's not
only for children.
It's for everyone."
And some of them
are more for adults.
And this is one of those.
It's a story that takes
place back in the times
when people really depended on
horses, when they were a part
of their daily lives,
as was death.
Something they had to deal with
and we have to deal with today.
It's called The Two
White Horses.
Amanda Jane fixed me
with her big, round eyes.
"Mama will be home
tomorrow, won't she, Jenny?"
She held tight to her ragdoll.
I almost said, "Mama will
never be back, Mandy,"
but I choked back the words.
How could you tell that
to such a little young'in?
When the neighbor women came to
get Mama ready for the burying,
they took Mandy and little
Joey over to the men's house.
Nales Woodsby brought
the box to lay Mama in.
They put on her best
taffeted dress,
the one with the stand-up
collar she only wore
to church on Sundays.
And on Mama's breast there
was pinned Aunt Jenny's pin,
beautiful.
She looks so beautiful
in that coffin.
Well, folks came and
it was Bert and Doc
who loaded up the coffin.
He loaded it up into the
back of the wagon and Bert
and Doc pulled that wagon
slow-like all the way
up to Graveyard Hill.
Mama always loved that view.
You could look out over
most of Greenup County
with the river winding below.
Meadowlarks were singing
and I could smell
honeysuckle on the warm air.
But I had a cold,
drizzly feeling inside.
The sunshine seemed all wrong.
Preacher Gorge made
a long sermon,
saying what a fine
woman Mama was
and telling things
from the Bible.
But I wished he wouldn't
talk so long.
I was afraid Papa was going
to break down and cry.
He looked so sad and stern.
Charline Moss and Leslie Crunk
sang, "You've Got to Walk
that Lonesome Valley."
You've got to walk it all alone.
I could just see Mama, dressed
in white, walking down a long,
lonesome road all by herself.
At the end, Papa asked them
to sing her favorite
hymn, Precious Memories.
I almost smothered when
they set down that coffin.
I could see Mama through a
little window in the lid.
It looked like she
was just asleep.
They commend to shove
them in the dirt.
I ran down the hill and
waited with Burton Dock.
Everybody left the graveyard
and we all walked home.
The house seemed
so empty and quiet,
the old clock ticking
on the mantle.
I missed Mama.
She was always busy
around the house,
and the kitchen smelled good
from things she'd have
cooking on the stove.
She'd call me to go carry a
bucket of water from the well
or go hunt the guinea's nest.
But she was gone now.
It seems like it took me a
long time to get supper ready.
Cornmeal mash had lumps in it
and it tasted kind of scorched.
But Papa said it was real
good and he was proud of me.
When bedtime came, little
Joey hollered for Mama.
He was terribly fussy
because he hadn't had his nap
on account of the burying.
I could hardly get him
into his trundle bed.
Didn't have no trouble
with Mandy though.
She sleeps with me.
Then Papa blew out
the lamp and climbed
into the big four-poster
bed in the corner, alone.
A huge moon came up behind
the barn, making dark shadows.
Chickens that perched in the
butternut tree were already
on their roosting limb.
Papa's gun was on its
rack over the door, ready,
in case anything
bad should happen.
I couldn't get to sleep.
I kept thinking about Mama
up there in that graveyard
with all those dead people.
Little Carter boy who jived
the thrash was near her.
Grass hadn't grown back
over his grave yet.
Over by the stone wall
was old Miss Crower.
She got so heavy, she
couldn't get out of her chair.
She died of heart dropsy.
Outside, the crickets
were chirping.
I wondered if they were chirping
up at the graveyard too.
Old Yellow Throat gave a few
clucks and chats from over
in the blackberry briars.
Sometimes he sings at night,
especially if there's
a big moon shining.
I felt all shivery.
Then I heard something else.
Slow footsteps came dragging
across the front porch.
There was a knock
at the front door.
Papa's bed creaked as he sat
up and reached for his clothes.
"Who's there?"
"Open the door, Clint.
It's me, Alphea,"
Mama's voice answered.
It sounded weak and far away.
"I've come home from the grave."
"No, no, go away,"
Papa almost shouted.
"You're a ghost that's
come to trouble me.
Oh, I'm wretched enough, Alphea.
My heart is wrung with sorrow."
"Open the door, Clint.
Let me in."
"No, Alphea.
It's the moon that's
got you awake.
The moon's so big
and strange tonight
and the shadows are so dark.
Go back to your grave
and sleep in peace.
No." "Let me in."
"No, Alphea, it's the moonlight
that's made you restless.
Last night it shone through
the window on your pale face,
and you a corpse
awaiting for the burying.
They say if it shines on
your face when you're asleep,
it will drive you mad.
Maybe even the dead."
"Oh, but I wasn't dead Clint.
I must have been in
a deep, dark sleep.
Believe me, truly I'm alive.
Oh, let me in before
it's too late."
The voice drifted away.
The little ones were so scared,
they hid under the covers.
I was scared too.
Papa turned to us and
he said, "Children,
if our two horses
have their heads
out of the stall windows
a-looking the way they do
when someone comes, I'll know
for sure it's your Mama."
He went over and he
drew up the shades.
"They're there.
Burt and Doc have
their heads out.
Did you hear Doc knicker?"
Papa hastened to the door
and he threw it open.
He caught Mama's arms just
as she was about to fall.
He carried her over the
bed and laid her across it.
"Jenny, run and make
Mama some hot comfy tea.
She's so cold.
Alphea, I saw Nales Woodsby
nail down that coffin lid
and dirt shuffled in on it.
How'd you escape?"
Mama took a deep breath.
"Well, a grave robber dug up my
coffin and pried off the lid.
He stole grandmother's broach,
but he couldn't get
my rings off.
He was trying to cut
away my fingers."
"What do you mean, Mama?
Then what?"
Well, the pain got me awake.
When I sat up and screamed,
that old man hollered too."
[ Laughter ]
"He dropped his knife
and went hopping away
across those graves.
It was that strange Ralph Sinion
who lives back in the swamps."
I tugged at Mama's sleeve.
"Mama, how'd you get
all the way home?"
She stroked my hair.
"Well, I pulled myself up out
of that coffin and walked home.
The moon was so bright
it lit up the fields.
I came by the crossroads,
took the old mill road
to the foot of our lane.
Oh, it was so far, so far."
"That dirty runion
stealing from the dead.
I'll stomp him!"
"Why, Clint, if it hadn't been
for that old scow, I'd still be
in my coffin, buried alive."
The next day, Papa took
a wide board and he sawed
out two horses' heads.
He painted them white like
Bert and Doc and he nailed them
to the side of the stall window
so we'd never forget
how it was those horses
that knew it was mama that
night in the moonlight
when she knocked at our door.
And that's a true story that
happened in Irwin, Tennessee.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
It still is one of my favorites.
And the woman that wrote the
words down to that story,
Eliza Sieman, I met her
when she was in her 70s.
God, I'm in my 70s.
Oh, my gracious.
I met her a long
time ago in 1974.
And she lived on this side of
Coffee Ridge and Tumbling Creek,
a tiny little community
outside of Irwin,
Tennessee, east Tennessee.
And she lived -- I went up
there and visited many times.
She lived at the end of
the dirt road and the end
of the gravel road, at
the end of the road.
And back during World
War II, she used to go
across the mountains,
Coffee Ridge,
and sit with a woman
named Becky Farner.
And this had happened to
someone in Becky's family.
And Eliza then wrote
the words down
and gifted me with the story.
And I told that story
at the second National
Storytelling Festival
when I was featured.
And now that was 44 years ago.
So that was the first
time that I told it.
I'm going to end, and I
will say that you know,
people used to really be
afraid of being buried alive.
And my dad was raised in
New Orleans, born in 1911.
And he said when anyone died,
that there was always this hope
they could somehow come back,
and also a fear that they might.
And people used to be buried
with a bell in their coffin.
I mean, actually the
string was in the coffin
and the string then was attached
to a bell outside
in the grave yard.
And it was so they
could pull that bell
if they had been buried alive.
And that's where we get the
phrase, saved by the bell.
So I'm going to end this
on one short little story,
and then Barbara's
going to come up
and then we'll move right along
for the rest of the evening.
This is one -- I
like to think of it
as bringing my Mama on stage.
I just told you about my daddy,
but Mary Agnes Freeman is
the one that told me this.
The telephone rang, and a voice
said, "Is your mama home?"
A little boy answered it, "No."
"Hmm. Is your daddy there?"
"No, he's busy."
"Oh. Is anybody else there?"
"Just the policeman."
"Oh, the policeman, may
I speak to him pleas?"
"He's busy."
"Well, what in the world
are they all doing?"
"They are all looking for me."
A story for you to
take away and tell.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Come right on up if you want.
>> I will.
>> Yeah, come on up
and I will come down.
They're going to
turn me off here.
>> Can somebody with
more muscles
than me bring a chair up here?
Thank you.
Well, I have arms but I
don't have my chainsaw.
[ Laughter ]
No, this will be fine, I think.
Let me see where I'm
going to put that puppy.
That was beautiful, Connie.
I just love that
Two White Horses.
That was just so special.
By the way, in relationship to
the bell above the graveyard,
most of those people
are Avon representatives
to this very day.
[ Laughter ]
Does the name Quasi
Modo ring a bell?
Bell ringing of Notre Dame.
I'm sorry.
Well, once but not
so very long ago,
there lived an old
man named Joseph.
Everybody called him Old Joe.
He was quite a character.
He had a great sense of
humor, and he loved rhymes
and riddles and songs and jokes.
He had a good life.
He was a farmer,
and he raised cows
and chickens and such as that.
And his garden was
the most beautiful
in the entire community,
because between the rows
of vegetables he had
beautiful flowers growing.
Even the cornstalk as it made
its way up to the sunshine,
he had planted a little
sunflower seed right next
to each one of them so his
whole garden was just full
of sunshine.
And he had something that
he was very grateful for,
a very best friend that
just lived a farm away.
Yes, sir, you could
go down Old Joe's hill
and his neighbor would
come down his hill.
There was a little
dip in the land
and these two friends
would meet there every day.
And you know, these
two elderly gentlemen,
they had a lot in common.
They were both widowers, so they
had that grief and that sorrow
to share about their
beloved wives.
But they also had all
that joy to talk about.
The potluck suppers, the church
picnics, the country dances
and just all four of
them getting together.
And Old Joe and his best friend,
when they met at that little dip
of the land each morning,
they would talk about religion
and politics and the
events of the day,
and their dreams
and their hopes.
And if one of them got
sick, the other was sure
to bring them a little something
to eat and maybe a funny story
to lift up their spirits.
Well, one day Joe
got powerful sick.
And he didn't show
up, and the neighbor,
he looked down his hillside
and up the other and he saw
that Joe's house was all shut
up tight, shutters and all.
And it looked really dreary.
And he saw that the horse and
the buggy were still there.
He knew something was wrong,
so he went into his kitchen way
and he made him some chicken
soup and he brought it
down the hill and up the other
side and knocked on the door.
And there was a very weak
voice said, "Come in."
And when the neighbor
opened the door
and he saw Old Joe
lying there like that,
he knew he was powerful sick.
So he tried to make a little
funny and he said, "Well, Joe,
you look like death eating a
cracker without the cracker."
And Joe said, "You know,
I've got the chills
and then I've got the fever, and
my bones ache all over my body.
I've never felt this bad before,
and I see you brought
me some food.
I appreciate you.
But just put it over there.
I don't think I can
eat anything."
And his neighbor just pulled
up a chair and he said, "Well,
you know, Joe, I'm going
to tell you something.
I really missed you down in our
little meeting place because I'm
out this morning early
milking my favorite cow early
and had my hand son
the udders there.
Putting that milk
right into the bucket,
and all of the sudden [buzzing]
there come this little old fly
and he was flying so funny-like.
He was doing spirals and dips
and dives and I noticed why.
One little wing was kind of torn
and tattered just a little bit.
And he [buzzing] went
right up to Earline's ear
and she was flicking that
ear and just moving around
and flashing her tail.
And I thought, "I'm going to end
up with churned butter
here if I'm not careful."
It really agitated my cow.
And all of the sudden, he
flew out and she settled down
and I kept on a-milking.
And then [buzzing]
went right into her ear
and I had to finish up.
I never did see the little thing
leave, but I finished my milking
and I'm heading back tom y house
and I'm thinking, you know,
I'm going to make --
are you feeling okay
for this, little buddy?
Okay, I'll go on then.
So I'm walking back to the house
and I'm thinking, you know,
I'm going to have the best cup
of coffee known to mankind.
I'm going to skim off
some of that cream
and -- yeah, I can't wait.
And I look down into the bucket
and there I saw doing
the backstroke on top
of that cream was that same
little fly what had been
in Earline's ear.
And I knew it was the same one
because its little wing was torn
and tattered a little bit.
And when I saw that, it
made me think of my mama.
She'd take that arthritic
finger and she'd say,
"You're not listening to me."
And then she'd say
something else."
And Joe said, "Well, you
know, I'm always able
to finish your stories
and riddles and such,
but with the fever, I
can't come up with it.
I just can't do it.
My brain is -- I can't do it.
It's too hot."
"Well, Joe, I'm going to
tell you the first line
of what my mama said and I know
you'll be able to finish it off.
When I saw that fly in that
milk, I said, "In one ear --
"" And Joe said,
"And out the udder."
[ Laughter ]
And you know, just that
little bit of a smile,
Joe found himself just
sitting up in the bed
and he said, "Hand me that soup.
I'm going to take it out."
And this is the way it always
was with these two best friends.
But one day something
happened to change all that.
They were down in that
little dip of the land
and they got into an argument.
And their voices
had some hate in it,
and their hearts were
filled with bitterness.
And they were shouting
at each other.
You see, a cow had given
birth to a little calf
and both neighbors were
claiming it as their own.
"Well, it's got the
markings of my favorite cow.
It doesn't take any more
than an idiot to see that."
"Well, your favorite cow
looks like all my cows,
and who's land do you think
it was born on anyway?"
And that's the way it went until
these two turned their backs,
one to the other, and they went
up their hillsides
without looking back.
And turned into their homes,
shut themselves inside,
warning never to speak again.
Well, the weeks went by and
Joe, he was feeling alone
and wanting company, but he
wasn't about to make amends.
And apparently neither
was his neighbor.
Now one day, there come a
knock at the door, and Joe went
to the door and he cracked
it open a little bit.
And he saw a young man standing
there and he had a toolbox full
of tools on his shoulder and Joe
said, "What be your business?"
And the young man said,
"Sir, I need a job of work.
I was wondering sir if you have
any projects I could help you
with around the farm.
Oh, mister, I really
need the work."
Well, Joe in his way said,
"Well, I may look old,
but let me tell you
something, young fella.
If something's broke around my
farm and needs fixing, I just --
" and all of the sudden he felt
in his heart, filled up with
that hunger, a hunger he had
for company and conversation,
just to talk to somebody.
And so he cut himself
short and he said, "Well,
I'll tell you what, young fella.
I don't reckon I have any
projects as you say to do,
but I tell you what I do have.
I've got me some
coffee to perking.
I've got some homemade
bread, fresh-churned butter.
Why don't you just come
in here and sit a spell
and we can have a
little chat or so.
And then you can be about
looking for your job of work."
And the young man
said he'd like that.
So he came in and they
sat down at the table.
And Joe, he started
telling him all kinds
of jokes and funny stories.
And the young man
was smiling real big
and Joe was just laughing
outright, and then all
of the sudden Joe glanced out
the window down his hillside
and his heart was
filled with resentment.
And he turned to the young
man and said, "You know,
I think I've got
a project for you.
Now look out that window way
there and you see out there
down at the bottom of my
hill we got a little ditch
that is supposed to be
now I guess called a creek
or something.
You see my neighbor
wants to divide us,
so he had a spring
pond up there.
And he takes his tractor
and he turned it out
and flooded this little
old dip in the land there,
and now we got ourselves a
bubbling brook, a little creek,
whatever you want to call it.
Now I'd like to do
him one better.
I would like for you to go
down by the water
and build me a fence.
And I mean a real tall fence
so I don't ever have to see him
or his cows or his
creek ever again.
Do you think you could do that?"
And the young man said,
"Joe, I've got the tools.
And if you've got the lumber,
I think I can do a job
you'll be well pleased with."
So Joe took him to the barn
and there was stacks and stacks
of wood and panels, lumber and
plenty enough to do the job.
And then Joe told him and
said, "I can't grow everything
and I need to go into town
and lay in some supplies.
But I'm telling you
what, young fella,
I'll be back before sunset,
because I want to
see that fence.
And make it mighty
tall, mighty tall."
And Joe, he got the
horse and the buggy
and he started on
off down the road.
Down that dusty road
toward town.
And that young man, he took
all those lumber planks
down creekside and his
work, it went really well.
He hammered, sawed and
fashioned with nails.
And he worked the whole day.
And just before sunset, Joe
pulled in and he got right
out of his buggy and he
just came around to the back
of his cabin so he
could see that fence.
But there was no fence at all.
But rather that young
man, he had built a bridge
and that bridge was going from
Joe's land across that creek
over to his neighbors.
And down the hillside was
coming Joe's neighbor.
And Joe headed down
his hillside.
And the neighbor was the
first to step onto the bridge
and he extended his hand.
"Oh, Joe, you're quite a man.
I'd have never thought of this.
I just want to be
your friend again."
"Yeah, I've missed you and
can I just say that all
that bitterness and those words
we had, we can just let them go
in one ear-- " And the neighbor
said, "And out the udder."
And then they were
walking across the bridge
and Joe told him, "We all
know the calf was yours.
But let me tell you something,
this idea about the bridge,
I wish it was mine, I really do.
But it wasn't.
It's this young fellow here."
And about that time, that young
man had taken that tool box,
put it back on his shoulders
and he was walking away.
Joe hollered after
him, "Hey, young fella,
I do like your projects and you
can tell I've got a lot of work
to do here at the farm.
I'd hire you up,
pay you a good wage.
You know, I'm a pretty good cook
and you can stay
in the bunkhouse."
"Joe, I would like that.
I would like that so very much,
but I've got to be moving on.
I've got more bridges to build."
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
So now I'm going to
tell you something
that five words are going
to help you remember.
And the five words are
"everybody knows old Dry Fry."
Now you can just turn to
the person closest to you
and say those five words.
It really helps us all
get our memory back.
That and coconut oil
will do the trick.
So everybody knows old Dry Fry.
Try it out.
Everybody knows old Dry Fry.
Yeah, boy.
Old Dry Fry was a
substitute preacher
and he loved to do that.
But what he loved
more than anything
in all the world
was fried chicken.
Now Dry Fry had a 9:00-5:00 job.
He was a veterinarian.
And right next to his little
veterinary, he had a taxidermy.
Now you know if you're
out fishing
and you catch a big
old huge bass,
you're not going to eat it.
You're going to take it to
a taxidermist and get him
to gut it out and put it on
a wooden board and tack it
up over the wall and you
can say that's the one
that never got away.
Well, Dry Fry was really known
for his veterinary
and his taxidermy.
But what he was most known for
was the sign he put out front.
It read, "Either way,
you get your dog back."
[ Laughter ]
And you know, people would
be coming down the road
or they'd be riding
in their buggies
or sweethearts would
be holding hands.
And they would see that sign and
they would turn one to another
and say five words,
"Everybody knows old Dry Fry."
Yeah, boy.
One day old Dry Fry was
at a church and picnic.
And nobody went to the
regular pastor to say, "Pastor,
please ask the Lord
to put the blessing
on the food so we can eat."
No, they went to Preacher Fry
because they knew he talked
so rapid and so fast, by the
time he got into the blessing
and pulled out, the
food would still be hot.
So Dry Fry allowed
he'd be glad to do it.
And he started in with the
blessing and one thing would pop
into his head and then
another and then another still,
and he'd say things
like, "Bless the farmer
that grew the bird we're going
to eat, bless the little seed
that went into the ground,
the little bud that came up
and the little bud that
grew into the big cornstalk.
And bless -- " he
went on and on.
And he got to talking so fast
that his false teeth got loose
and they flung out of
his mouth and dropped
down deep into a mudhole.
And everybody wanted to help
out Preacher Fry and fish
out them teeth for him and
all, but nobody was willing
to put their hand down into that
mud and get worms or nothing,
or worse yet get bit
by them chompers.
And that's when little Amandy
Durrigan, sharp as a tack,
11 years old, bright
little girl, she went right
over to a picnic basket, got
herself out a big old piece
of friend chicken, tied a string
onto it, brought that chicken
over above that mudhole
and dangled it for bait.
And sure enough, them old
teeth come flying up out
of that mudhole, latched rung
onto that piece of chicken.
It took three grown adults to
rip and tear that chicken meat
out from betweenst
them working chompers.
And then somebody came up
with some homemade lemonade,
rinsed them off, mud
and worms and all
and drip-dried them
a little bit.
And then there was a little boy
with a beautiful
little sweet heart.
And he came up with this
half-eaten jar of peanut butter.
And he dug in there real deep
and he put some peanut butter
up on top of them chompers
for sticking power,
gave those teeth back to Dry
Fry and he was as good as new.
But he finished the
blessing with one word.
"Amen." And everybody turned one
to another and said five words,
"Everybody knows old Dry Fry."
Now I have picked a person out
of the audience to help tell
with me the last
scene of Dry Fry.
So Tom, come on up here.
[ Applause ]
You can come up that way.
And do you have your microphone?
>> I do.
>> All right.
I love to do this
when I tell Dry Fry.
I always pick somebody
out of the audience.
So count your blessings and
let this be one of them.
What I always say to my
volunteer is I pick a volunteer
that has no sense of pride
about them whatsoever.
Oh, you wore a hat.
That is so good.
Okay. So to help us
get started into this,
I'm going to need five words.
>> Everybody knows old Dry Fry.
>> Yeah, boy.
One day old Dry Fry
was at the county fair,
looking around for
his best friend.
Brother Henry, give me five.
Brother Henry, I hear tell,
here at the fair they're willing
to sell some of their
prized horses.
>> Well, let's get us a couple.
>> That's a great idea.
Look, reach out with
your hand here.
Wow. Here's two fine-looking
horses.
We're going to put them
in the same pasture.
Stepping back and looking
at these two fine critters,
you know, I think they
look exactly alike.
I don't know how we're ever
going to tell them apart.
>> Identical.
>> Identical has a
whole new meaning.
They're practically twins.
I don't how we're
going to tell my horse
from -- oh, I've got it.
Let's measure them.
Well, I never.
>> I never too.
>> Let's measure
them the other way.
Well, I never.
>> I never too.
>> They are exactly alike.
I don't know how we're ever
going to tell them apart.
Oh, I've got it.
You stand there.
I'm going to go back here
behind this horse closest
to me, Brother Henry.
Raise up that tail, take off
some of them scraggly hairs
and that other horse over
there with the long tail,
well that will just be yours.
See you tomorrow.
>> See you tomorrow too.
>> Oh, well, I never.
>> I never too.
They both got sawed-off tails.
Must have got caught
in the brambly bushes.
They're the same again.
Now I don't know how we're
going to tell them apart.
Oh, I've got it.
Just on this horse
closest to me,
I'm going to take a little
clip off of this one's ear
and that other one over
there with the full ears,
well that's going to be yours.
See you tomorrow.
>> See you tomorrow too.
>> Well, I never.
>> Well, I never too.
>> They both got clips
out of their ears.
Must have got caught in
the barby wire fence.
They're the same again.
I don't know how we're ever
going to tell them apart.
What are we going to do?
I'm plumb out of ideas.
>> I got an idea.
>> Let's have it.
>> You take the black one
and I'll take the white one.
[ Laughter ]
>> There you go.
Wahoo. I told you no pride.
[ Applause ]
Oh Tom, that was so beautiful.
You were so good.
[ Applause ]
And I've been telling stories
for 48 years and Tom is fresh
out of the audience,
but he is fabulous.
Thank you, Tom.
That was so wonderful.
And Tom's beautiful wife
is Janet, and Connie
and I would stay with their
family year after year
after year when we first
started traveling on the road.
So it was a second home for us
and we were always
welcome there.
So is that it for me?
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, we're going to have an
interview now, and then Connie
and I will end on
another folk teller story.
Y'all are so cool.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
Thank you, sweetie.
Okay.
[ Inaudible ]
I think you should sit on
that end, and Connie and I --
That way we don't have to
swivel our heads around.
All right.
>> Thea Austen: Y'all
doing okay?
So we'll just do a little
short thing here and --
>> Steve Winick: All right.
Hey.
>> Steve.
>> Steve Winick: Hi.
>> Yay.
>> Steve Winick: My
name is Steve Winnick.
I'm the editor in the
American Folk Life Center
and I'll just be doing a brief
interview here to bring out some
of the background
to the folk tellers
and some of these stories.
And in particular,
I think one thing
that people are usually
interested in is the story
of how you guys got started
as professional storytellers.
So you know, you were
telling me before
about how the storytelling scene
has kind of shifted from a lot
of traditional stories to a lot
of personal experience stories.
So now I'm asking for
the tandem telling
of your personal experience.
>> Well, Barbara
was a children's
and young adult librarian
in Chattanooga.
And I went to visit her
and I had just gotten back
from spending a year
hitchhiking around in Europe.
And I was really hoping
to go back to Europe.
But I went to visit Barbara,
my dear first cousin.
And she told me about this job.
>> The librarian here has
written a big, wonderful grant
for disadvantaged children,
economically poor kids
and we need a storyteller to be
in a cute little van all
covered with daisies.
And you get to give
out books to children.
And even if they're in bed with
five other kids at their house
and something happens bad to
the book, you know, we want them
to know that honey,
you get another book.
This time put it on top
of your refrigerator.
And we just want them to have
a complete love of books.
And Connie was Miss
Daisy in the blue dress
with daisies all over it.
She matched the van.
And she was fantastic.
>> And that was really the best
of children's literature too.
It wasn't just you know,
the inexpensive books
on the corner shelf.
It was really the award-winners,
Caldecott Award and all that.
The program is actually
still going on.
>> It is.
>> It started in 1971.
That's when I started
as a storyteller,
and it's still going on.
And then Barbara and I
quit those library jobs.
We really loved them, but
we had started doing --
>> Steve Winick: Well,
we appreciate libraries
and library jobs.
>> Yeah, we do.
>> We do.
>> Steve Winick: How to
parlay your library job
into a glamorous
life of storytelling.
>> That's right.
And during that time I had heard
about the first National
Storytelling Festival.
And I wrote Jimmy Neil Smith
who was putting it on and said,
"I'm a storyteller
in Chattanooga.
My cousin and I both tell."
And he said, "Come on up."
And we ended up telling
at that very first one.
And within a couple
of years after that,
we decided to quit
those jobs we loved
and got a little pickup truck
with a topper on it and put all
of our belongings and lived
and traveled out of that.
>> It was a Dotson pickup truck.
And when I bought it, it was red
and I thought it
was a fire engine.
So I had the first yellow
Dotson pickup truck,
the really small kind.
And so we named it DPUT,
Dotson Pickup Truck.
200,000 miles on that old puppy
and it was really wonderful.
>> Yeah. And so then we
started traveling and lots
of people invited
us onto the stages
of the Folk Music
Festivals back in those days
and things just kept unfolding.
>> Steve Winick: All right.
So that's a great
way to get started.
And there's a person or a family
that was particularly important
in getting you inspired and
started, and there's pictures
of them outside on
the table out there.
We're talking about
the Hicks family,
particularly Ray and Rosa Hicks.
>> Yeah.
>> Steve Winick: So tell us
about how you came together
with them and how
they inspired you.
>> We met them at the very first
national storytelling festival,
1973 there in Jonesborough,
Tennessee.
They'd come down out of the
mountains, this giant of a man,
really a giant in so many ways.
But literally 6-feet-7-inches
tall.
They invited him
up onto this stage.
There was actually a recording
of this that I still have.
And he told one of
the Jack tales.
And afterwards, Barbara
and I both went up to him
and met his wife Rosa who
stood just barely five feet --
there's a picture of her out
there on the table as well.
And we walked all around
town that day and we all fell
in love with each other.
And then that began this dear
friendship that lasted for me
with them until Ray passed
away on April 21st in 2003.
And Rosa passed away
in 2012 I think it was.
>> I'd like to say
something here too.
Because I just admire
Connie so much.
And the Hicks family
still had the outhouse.
They still had to go out to the
spring to get all their water
to wash their dishes and to
boil their food and whatever.
And Connie was very instrumental
in taking carpenters
and raising money,
fundraising and stuff like that,
f-u-n and f-u-n-d raising
for Ray Hicks and Rosa.
Got them in an addition
built onto their house.
And the other part sometimes
was filled with snakes
that would come up through the
cracks and the wood was so --
anyway, renovated but still
looked like the old home place.
And gave them flush
toilets and water pipelined
in so they could still go to
the outhouse if they wanted
to for nostalgic reasons.
But they didn't have to in
the cold, bitter winter.
And so I just think that --
Connie has even gone to Africa
and me women that
are so impoverished,
but they did have a means of
taking magazines from America,
you know, and tearing the
pages and putting a little bit
of glue-type on it to where
it looked like a real jewel.
Do you have on one right now?
See how real that looks?
It's paper magazines.
And so Bead For Life, Connie was
very instrumental in coming back
to America and telling
the story of these women
and selling their stuff for them
and sending the money
back to them.
So I just admire you
to pieces for that.
>> Oh, thank you.
That's very dear to my heart.
>> And you probably didn't tell
them that in the interview.
>> I didn't.
Yeah.
>> Steve Winick: All right.
Well, another thing
that did come
up in the interview
was a particular story
that Connie, you had about Ray.
And it involves your
license plate.
>> Oh yeah, that's cute.
>> Yeah. So I was asked by the
Candinsky trio, a piano trio,
cello, violin and piano, to
do storytelling with them.
And we created based
on Ray Hicks' version
of Wicked John the Devil,
and also Barbara Freeman's
version of that story.
We created a story called
the Cantankerous Blacksmith.
And our intention was all
four of us were telling it
on stage as a quartet.
Sometimes only the
violin, sometimes only me,
sometimes all four of us.
And we toured this all over.
And there were nine presenting
universities that said, "Yes,
we will do this new work,"
which is quite a challenge
for chamber music often.
And they were up and
down the Appalachians.
One of those was at
Boone at the University,
Appalachian State, yeah.
Appalachian State.
And this was before Ray
and Rosa had a telephone
or that indoor plumbing.
And so I had written them
and told them about this
that was going to happen.
And I had no idea if they
were going to be able to come.
I had arranged several people
that could maybe pick them up,
but they'd have to write
them or just go and see
if they wanted to come.
And it was a highlight of my
life walking out on stage,
the trio and I in tuxes -- I had
a glittery, slivery white outfit
with black tux -- and
seeing Ray and some
of his family sitting
in the second row.
And Ray listened to
that storytelling.
Such an odd way probably
to his ear,
but laughing and
slapping his leg.
And afterwards we walked outside
and we were saying our goodbyes.
And Ray said for me, he asked me
to not let anyone
ever forget him.
So I tell a lot of the stories,
I carry his pictures
wherever I go.
And he turned to me and he said,
"Connie, tell on, tell on."
And that's now my license tag.
[ Laughter ]
Thanks for asking.
>> Steve Winick: So
I wanted to make sure
that we didn't forget Ray
as well, bringing that up.
>> Yeah.
>> Steve Winick:
Another story that came
up in our interview
earlier today was one
of Barbara's stories about
telling a particular story
in a particular place and
the importance of that.
Could you tell the audience
a little about that?
>> Do you want me to
actually do a couple
of scenes but Cliffnote it?
>> Steve Winick: Yeah,
that would be great.
>> Okay. Well, I was asked
where was my favorite place
to tell a favorite story.
And I actually went
to Jerusalem.
I had to sell all of my
Limber Jacks, you know,
those little dancing dolls
that you see on a paddle
and you hit the paddle and you
lower the doll and the dance?
I had 82 of them but
I was keeping two
and I called Gale Haley,
a famous illustrator too.
She won the Caldecott medal.
And I said, "Gale,
you've seen me
at book conferences and stuff.
I want to go to Jerusalem
and Bethlehem
and Nazareth, the holy land.
It's $999."
And she said, "Well," --
she said, "I will come there
because I really like those.
They look like real people."
Like you have one
that's Mini Pearl
with the little tag on her hat.
And I had roosters and
frogs and just everything.
So she came and she said,
"Barbara, I'll give you $1,000."
And I said, "That is terrific.
Isn't that just like the Lord
to give you one lousy buck once
you've got there, you know?"
I was very blessed to go.
I really enjoyed it.
But when I was there --
[ Laughter ]
When I was there, I
thought here I am you know,
walking the Villa de la Rosa
for the crucifixion of Jesus,
and here I am on
Bethlehem on my birthday.
And so when it came time for
me to tell a story there,
I thought about telling
my favorite story
which is the Tale
of Three Trees.
And three trees are
dreaming about what they want
to be when they grow up.
And one wants to -- he sees
the stars in the heavens
and he wants to hold
magnificent diamonds
like the stars and jewels.
And he wants to be made into
a beautiful treasure chest.
Another tree sees the creek
going by, making its way
to the mighty waters
of the ocean.
And he wants to be
a sailing ship,
a wooden sailing ship that's
so powerful and so strong
that he would be the one
to carry kings to and fro.
And the third tree just wanted
to stay on the mountaintop
and grow so tall and taller
still that when people wanted
to look at me, they'd
have to raise their eyes.
And when they did, I
would point to heaven
and perhaps they
would think of God.
I will be the tallest
tree in the world.
Well the years go by and the
rain came down, and the sun,
and they grew tall
and taller still.
And one day, three woodcutters
came to the top of the mountain
and the first one went over
to the first tree and said,
it's perfect for
what my needs are.
And with the last swoop of his
ax, the tree fell, thinking,
"I will be inlaid with gold
and silver and hold treasure."
The second woodcutter
went to the second tree
and said, "Looks strong.
I'll take it."
With the last two swoop-swoop of
his ax, the tree fell thinking,
"I will sail the mighty waters
of the ocean, a sailing ship."
The third tree, she stood so
tall and straight and still
and she pointed to heaven.
But that woodcutter, he did
not even look up at her.
"Any old tree will
do for me," he said.
He came over and with his
ax, the third blow took
down the third three,
swoop, swoop, swoop.
And she fell.
The years went by.
The three trees had almost
forgotten their dreams.
Because the first tree, when
it was cut, it was taken
to a carpenter's shop.
"I will be inlaid with gold."
But that carpenter, he was not
thinking of treasure chests.
He needed something
more practical.
So with his work-worn hands,
he built a simple feed box
and it was inlaid with
something, if you will, sawdust.
And it was taken to a farm and
placed there so that hay was put
into it and animals could
come up and eat out of it.
The second tree was
taken to the shipyards,
but they were not building
the strong vessels.
So the second tree was made
into a small fishing boat,
too small to sail a river,
much less the mighty
waters of the ocean.
So he sailed to and fro,
to and fro with a cargo
of dead, smelly fish.
And the third tree was just
taken to a lumber yard,
made into some beams
and left there.
So they had almost forgotten
their dreams, but one cold,
bitter winter night,
golden starlight shone
down on the first tree
as a young mother placed her
newborn babe onto the hay.
Her husband said, "I wish
I could have made a cradle
for him."
But that mother when she
saw that smooth, sturdy wood
and that golden starlight
on her baby,
she touched her husband's
arm and she said,
"This manger is beautiful."
And suddenly the first tree
knew he was holding the greatest
treasure on earth.
And the second tree is
sailing in the quiet lake
when a traveling man and his
companions come and one by one
by one, they get onto the small
fishing boat and it starts
out on the quiet lake.
And then something happened.
There was a terrible storm.
The thunder, the
lightning, the hurling wind.
And the waters of
the quiet lake became
like the angry waves
of the ocean.
And the passengers
were so frightened
and the second tree
said, "I'm too small,
to weak to carry these
passengers safely to shore.
They will all perish."
And just then that traveling man
who was so tired and had gone
to sleep, he woke up and
he stretched out his hand
and he said, "Peace, be still."
And as soon as he spoke,
there was no more storm,
and the waters were quiet again.
And the second tree knew
that he was carrying the king
of heaven and earth.
Do you want me to tell
about the third tree?
>> Steve Winick:
You might as well.
[ Laughter ]
>> That's the cliffhanger.
Well, the third tree
was so confused.
"What has happened?
All I ever wanted
to do was to stay
on the mountaintop
and point to God.
What's happened?"
It was on a Friday.
She was roughly shaken
and removed
from the forgotten woodpile.
She was carried through a
mob of angry, jeering people
and they were picking up
the waste from the streets
and hurling it at her.
And then she shuddered
in her heart
when a soldier nailed a
man's hands and feet to her.
And she felt cruel
and ugly and harsh.
And then she heard the man
say, "Father, forgive them,
for they know not what they do."
And the third tree felt sorrow.
But on Sunday morning, when
the sun rose in the heavens
and the earth trembled with
joy beneath the third tree,
suddenly she realized God's
love had changed everything.
It had made the first
tree beautiful.
It had made the second
tree strong.
And whenever anyone thought on
the third tree, they would think
of God, and that was better
than being the tallest
tree in the world.
So that's what I
told in Jerusalem.
[ Applause ]
>> Steve Winick: So it looks
like I turned the
interview into another story.
[Laughs]
>> Sorry about that.
>> That happens as storytellers.
>> Steve Winick: I think I had
better let you tell your tandem
story, your last tandem story.
>> Okay, that sounds good.
>> I've been waiting
for that story
like Old Joe and the Carpenter.
It was anonymous, and both of
them are over 100 years old.
>> Thank you very much, Steve.
[ Applause ]
As we are closing
for this evening,
we also want to thank
Todd Harvey.
He and Valda have been
my main contacts here
for getting my collection going.
It's now up online which
I'm thrilled about.
And Todd was called out of
town on a family emergency,
so he wasn't able
to be here tonight,
but we are thinking about him.
And we'll dedicate
this last story to him.
And we mentioned about us
being first cousins and such.
And we used to always gather
down in Polatka, Florida.
>> Yeah, we are two of 13
cousins and we would get
on a train or we would drive
up with our families in cars
from Birmingham and Nashville,
Tennessee and all over.
And we'd all gather at my cousin
Cindy's place and our Uncle Phil
in order to spend all
summer long after school
with our beloved grandfather
Samuel Enos Freeman.
>> And Pop Freeman
taught us a lot,
but he taught each one
of us about fishing.
And we kind of each
developed our own style.
And once I was sitting down
a long the bank of the river.
Big live oaks down
there in Polatka,
Florida with heavy moss hanging.
It's hidden just a little bit.
And I was sitting on the bank
there doing a little fishing
and my cousin Barbara
Ann walked up.
>> Hey Connie Sue
What you doing, honey?
>> Well, I'm fishing.
>> Fishing?
I don't see a pole.
>> Nope. Don't need one.
>> I don't see a line
or a hook or anything.
>> Nope, don't need one.
>> You ain't got that,
how are you fishing?
>> I got me this here
plug of chewing tobacco.
And what I do is I
just break some off
and I sprinkle it
out over that water.
Those fish come right
up to the surface,
grab some of that
chewing tobacco
and dive back down
into the water.
>> I still don't see
how that's fishing.
>> Well, those fish, they
got to come up to spit.
When they do, I got
me a big stick.
And I just hit them
over the head.
>> Have you caught
very many that way?
>> Well, just the other day I
caught me a 10-pound minnow.
>> Uh-huh, well I'll tell you
about my fishing
adventure then, Connie Sue.
You know, I was out
in evening time,
going to be doing some
shrimping in Pop's rowboat.
And I had his lantern
there, right there.
And I'm out there and I took
one of those weights and put it
in my mouth to cast out the
net to catch me some shrimp.
And when I did it, it knocked
Pop's lantern right off
and down into that water.
>> Ooh, I'm sure Pop wasn't
too pleased about that.
>> Not a talk, but let
me finish the story.
Let me tell you what happened.
I was out there just
yesterday with a pole
and a line and a hook.
And I hooked up that
self-same lantern.
>> I heard of that kind
of thing happening before
with boots and all.
>> Yeah, but Connie Sue,
this lantern was still lit.
>> Barbara Ann, I'll take nine
and three-quarter pounds off
that minnow if you'll at
least blow out that lantern.
[Blows].
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
I think that's good.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
>> Yay.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.